herzlich willkommen an den
empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute live euro
ihren live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussionen und die
diskussion im land ist derzeit seit dem
wochenende die große frage ob das
öffentliche leben in deutschland wieder
teilweise oder sogar komplett
heruntergefahren werden muss angesichts
der korona pandemie sogar vor einem
kontrollierten kontrollverlust warnen
manche da gibt es große sorgen dass das
ähnlich aussehen könnte wie in manch
anderen eu-ländern und da haben sich
heute schon die ersten
ministerpräsidenten dahingehend geäußert
zb markus söder in bayern oder armin
laschet in nordrhein-westfalen wir hört
mal rein
der größte schaden für die wirtschaft
ist eine verschleppte situation
das ist das was auf dauer des
schwierigstes deswegen ist für uns
wichtig dass wir jetzt den risiken ins
auge schauen und vernünftig und klug
damit umgehen verzögern wird nicht
helfen verschleppen verschlimmert lage
ist sehr sehr ernst und die bisher
geltenden maßnahmen reichen offenkundig
nicht aus um diesen trend zu stoppen
und deshalb kommt es jetzt auf ein
beherztes dieser ernsten lage
angemessenes handeln der politik an
so da sind quasi die statements von
markus söder und von armin laschet waren
dass sie sehen neben mir schon
constantin coole innenpolitischer
sprecher der fdp bundestagsfraktion die
fdp hat sich in den letzten monaten ja
immer wieder kritisch geäußert dass das
dass parlamente quasi umgangen werden
dass die maßnahme einfach so beschlossen
werden
was antworten sie diesen beiden
statements herr coole also als ist doch
völlig klar wir haben es nach wie vor
mit einem gefährlichen virus zu tun dass
eine heimtückische krankheit auslöst und
deswegen müssen die ministerpräsidenten
müssen die parlamente und müssen auch
alle bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt
zusammenstehen und daran arbeiten dass
man die situation wieder in den griff
bekommt aber die frage ist mit welchen
maßnahmen und wie werden diese maßnahmen
beschlossen
bei der frage welche maßnahmen
angemessen sind müssen wir glaube ich
die maßnahmen und die erfahrung die wir
in den letzten monaten sammeln konnten
jetzt anwenden es macht überhaupt keinen
sinn in der gastronomie bei kleinen
geschäften bei kulturbetrieben jetzt
wieder so strikt vorzugehen
wie das im märz und april der fall
gewesen ist und wir können bei der art
und weise einfach nicht akzeptieren dass
einfach ministerpräsidenten einen
überbietungswettbewerb aufführen und
dann über irgendwelche pressekonferenzen
bekanntgeben was beschlossen worden ist
die diskussion muss auch wieder in die
parlamente zurückgeführt werden also das
ist die ganz grobe linie der fdp die wir
uns jetzt in den nächsten minuten genau
ansehen werden hoffentlich auch mit
euren und ihren fragen und kommentaren
wie immer gerne in die dafür
vorgesehenen spalten will gucken rein
oder auch gerne per mail an zdf heute -
live at zdf.de das wird mir dann rüber
gereicht hier und wir schauen mal was
wir davon beantwortung kommen dann ist
auch schon die einblendung und dann
gucken wir mal worüber wir jetzt reden
können herr kohler aber wenn ich jetzt
mal gucken was heute so in den tickern
los war also es gab jede menge meldungen
heute nachmittag die wissenschaftler der
deutschen nationalen
wissenschaftsakademie leopoldina und
fünf andere forschungsgemeinschaften
haben gefordert
das ist eine drastische reduzierung von
sozialen kontakten gibt der virologe
christian drosten in seinem podcast am
ende er auch spd gesundheitspolitiker
karl lauterbach den wir gleich noch
hören werden
der wirbt für einen wellenbrecher
shutdown hat er das
genannt bei denen wir das öffentliche
leben quasi kurz heruntergefahren für
eine bestimmte zeit zwei bis drei wochen
und dann aber radikal das soll helfen
quasi die ausbreitung des virus
einzudämmen
das könnte morgen beschlossen werden
wenn die sich wieder zusammensetzen kann
man da jetzt wirklich sich als politiker
ruhigen gewissens hinsetzen und sagen
lasst das mal lieber die leute in
alleine entscheiden wenn so viele
wissenschaftler und große institutionen
sagen wir brauchen ja quasi geeignete
gemeinsame maßnahmen so einfach ist es
nicht ich glaube man muss dankbar sein
für diese wortmeldung aus der
wissenschaft wir haben da eine
großartige wissenschaftliche community
in deutschland die sich in den letzten
monaten auch sehr verdient gemacht hat
in der beratung der politik aber wenn
diese beratung der politik das ergebnis
zu tage fördert das die meisten
infektionen im privaten bereich
stattfinden das private zusammenkünfte
das private feiern das problem sind dann
können wir doch nicht ernsthaft
einerseits entwicklungen zu lassen und
wegschauen wo 200 300 400 leute private
feiern gemeinsam veranstalten und da
wird nicht kontrolliert und gleichzeitig
wird dann auf dem land wo die
bevölkerungsdichte wesentlich geringer
ist gastwirten die jetzt in den letzten
monaten geld investiert haben in
heizpilze beispielsweise der laden dicht
gemacht so geht es nicht die
verschiedenen wortmeldungen müssen auch
zusammenpassen und deswegen bin ich
dankbar für die wortmeldung aus der
wissenschaft aber der 1 liter auto von
versierte ansätze dass sie dafür sind
dass solche privaten feiern kontrolliert
werden von ordnungsämtern und von der
polizei das passt nicht zu der fdp dinge
die ich so kenne also erstmal geht es ja
damit los dass wir uns anschauen welche
maßnahmen bringen tatsächlich was und
hier ist es so dass ein großer teil der
infektionen im privaten bereich
stattfindet und natürlich kann man
darüber nachdenken ob man ähnlich zu den
regelungen im märz und im april eine
beschränkung für die zahl der haushälter
erlässt eine beschränkung für die zahl
der menschen er lässt die in einer
wohnung zusammen kommen können das kann
man tun
was nicht geht ist dass die polizei dann
klingelt und in privatwohnungen aus
forscht wie viele personen sich dort aus
wie viele personen sich dort aufhalten
also eigenverantwortung gehört bei der
durchsetzung der korona regeln schon
dazu
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt aber es
gehört auch dazu dass man im privaten
bereich darauf achtet und dass man auch
entsprechende regeln
wie das im frühjahr der fall gewesen ist
aber wir können nicht wieder übers ziel
hinausschießen und jetzt diejenigen
menschen treffen die sich doch in den
letzten monaten gedanken darüber gemacht
haben über plexiglas über eine änderung
des raumkonzepts über eine änderung der
beschränkung der personenzahl in ihren
geschäften oder in ihrem fitnessstudio
oder in ihrer kultureinrichtungen ihrer
kleinkunstbühne all diejenigen die sich
jetzt die letzten monate angestrengt
haben das gerade keine infektion
stattfinden die kann man jetzt nicht
beschränken sondern wir müssen uns darum
kümmern dass im privaten bereich
aufgepasst wird das hat mit
eigenverantwortung zu tun und hier darf
der staat nicht ein denunziantentum
befördern
aber es muss auch klar sein was dazu
beiträgt die infektionen einzuhalten und
einzudämmen und was nicht aber die frage
ist ja ob das mit der eigenverantwortung
so gut funktioniert wir hätten gerne
heute abend mit ihnen und karl
lauterbach zusammen diskutiert der hat
leider heute abend leider keine zeit
gehabt aber er hat uns ein paar
statements vorher gegeben die haben wir
zusammen geschnitten und wir schauen mal
rein oder hören mal rein warum er jetzt
eigentlich fordert dass das öffentliche
leben komplett heruntergefahren wird für
zwei bis drei wochen
[Musik]
wir müssen die kontakte deutlich
reduzieren wir sind derzeit im
exponentiellen wachstum
wenn wir so weitermachen dann verdoppelt
sich quasi die zahl der neuinfizierten
jede woche die zahl der
intensivpatienten alle vielleicht acht
bis zehn tage deshalb nur wenige wochen
durch das heißt wenn wir jetzt nicht so
etwas machen wir an so genannten
wellenbrecher shutdown womit wir diese
welle die es auf uns zu durchbrechen
dann sind wir in wenigen wochen dem
kompletten lockdown sowie im frühjahr
weiter so wird also karl lauterbach spd
gesundheitsexperte wir diskutieren heute
mit constantin coole fpd
innenpolitischer sprecher der
bundestagsfraktion in berlin mehr
zugeschaltet gehen sie damit herr coole
oder ist das jetzt eine dramatisierung
der lage das hat ihr parteivorsitzender
letzte woche in einem gastbeitrag mal
gesagt hat gesagt dass quasi überall
alarmismus finden sie das alles muss was
herr lauterbach gesagt hat ich finde es
problematisch dass wir offensichtlich
nur zwei seiten haben wir haben
diejenigen die sagen ist alles quatsch
es gibt gar kein corona wir sollten am
liebsten alle maßnahmen seien lassen
das ist eine ganz gefährliche haltung
wir müssen uns ganz klar davon
distanzieren und müssen aufpassen dass
wir es als gesellschaft hinbekommen
gemeinsam gegen dieses virus vorzugehen
und dann haben wir protagonisten auf der
anderen seite und da ist herr lauterbach
ganz klar vorne mit dabei
denen die maßnahmen nicht streng genug
sein können und die überhaupt keine
rücksicht darauf nehmen was das für
auswirkungen auf das soziale auf das
wirtschaftliche auf das leben in der
bundesrepublik hat um das muss auch eine
rolle spielen
und deswegen müssen wir doch einfach mal
berücksichtigen was wir über den sommer
gelernt haben dazu gehört dass wir
freiräume schaffen auch für gastronomie
für kultur für kleine betriebe die sich
mühe geben auch unter den bedingungen
der korona pandemie bekämpfung am leben
zu bleiben und dass wir auch auf das
soziale miteinander in deutschland
achten schauen wir uns zum beispiel an
wie viele menschen im sommer in
betreuungseinrichtungen in altenheim in
hospizen gewesen sind teilweise
verstorben sind und nicht von ihren
angehörigen begleitet werden konnten
hier müssen wir darauf achten dass es
nicht zu pauschal maßnahmen kommt
sondern dass man sich im einzelnen
anschaut ist eine solche maßnahme
sinnvoll oder macht sie mehr kaputt als
das ihm nutzt ich habe
und hahn schau ich mal rein auch genau
die beiden pole die sie gerade
beschreiben herr coole die einen werden
jetzt hier ausfällig und beleidigend ein
auto braucht dann würde ich doch mal
darum bitten dass sein zu lassen
das bringt hier niemand weiter und ist
auch nicht ziel dieses creams wir wollen
konstruktiv versuchen eine lösung zu
finden oder zumindest die argumente
auszutauschen
die gibt es jetzt ein argument von
schwellen wollen nick auf facebook der
meint beachtet doch keiner im privaten
drauf egoismus ist wichtiger und wenn
wir uns mal die zahlen angucken das
haben jetzt mal ganz nüchtern versucht
zu tun ohne eine bewertung dann sieht
das ja doch gerade alles nicht zurück
laut robert-koch-institut melden die
gesundheitsämter heute insgesamt elf
1409 corona neuinfektionen
blickt man einmal genau vier wochen
zurück dann waren es am 26 september
insgesamt 2500 und sieben neuinfektionen
für bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier
eine exponentielle anstieg er warnte
schon ende dieser woche werde es
wahrscheinlich 20.000 fälle am tag geben
mittlerweile leben 64 millionen menschen
in einem risikogebiet einem areal also
mit über 50 neuinfektionen pro 100.000
einwohner in den letzten sieben tagen
auch bei den klinikbehandlungen gehen
die zahlen wieder nach oben
derzeit liegen in deutschland 1470 cupid
patienten auf den intensivstationen also
alles nicht so richtig super wird
diskutieren heute abend mit constantin
coole innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp
bundestagsfraktion in berlin
sie haben ja schon gesagt also sie
warnen auch sie erkennen die gefahr des
us- alles überhaupt keine frage aber sie
möchten andere maßnahmen sie möchten
quasi lernen sie haben das wiederholt
gesagt gastronomie und hotelbetriebe
nicht dicht machen die kleinen betriebe
die sich einen kopf gemacht haben eben
nicht bestrafen vielleicht könnte man
sagen aus ihrer perspektive
aber wenn ich mir angucke zum beispiel
ihr eigener parteichef christian lindner
im mai ist erwischt worden wie er aus
einem bekannten berliner restaurant
ausging und dann einem dem honorarkonsul
von weißrussland um den arm in arm fiel
quasi und umarmt hat ohne schutzmaske
hinter entschuldigt meinte ja es werden
fehler gewesen ich bin auch nur ein
mensch aber wenn das schon prominenten
passiert die es eigentlich besser wissen
dann sind wir halt auch alle nur
menschen ist es vielleicht nicht doch
besser damals zu sagen okay wenn es halt
anders nicht geht müssen wir halt mit
solchen maßnahmen angehen
ja aber sie können ja nicht hinter jedem
menschen ob prominent oder nicht einen
polizisten stellen dann darauf achtet
wie viele leute man oder ob man leute
umarmt also ich sage ganz ehrlich dass
wir auch in den letzten monaten es
mitunter passiert ist dass ich jemandem
die hand aus versehen gegeben habe oder
fast auch sozusagen die hand gegeben
habe nur es ist mir wesentlich weniger
passiert als dass ich mich besonnen habe
und mir in einer situation dann
eingefallen ist ach das ist ja ein
infektionsrisiko das lässt sie jetzt mal
lieber herr coole wenn sie nicht quasi
verführt werden indem sie halt auch
abends weggehen können sich im
restaurant treffen können sondern immer
merken okay es ist dichte können
eigentlich gar nicht also bleiben wir
alle zu hause aber es ist doch immer
eine frage von wahrscheinlichkeiten auch
zu hause haben sie am menschen aus ihrer
familie mit denen sie zusammen sind auch
über ostern beispielsweise über einen
urlaub den man vielleicht im sommer
miteinander verbracht hat ist man ja im
kontakt mit menschen gewesen und auch
sehr eng in kontakt mit menschen gewesen
das problem ist dass wir nur über
maßnahmen reden oder dass wir eine
polarisierung dieser debatte haben wo
ihr heim sagen es gibt überhaupt keinen
corona oder man kann sowieso nichts
machen
die anderen sagen es muss eine
hundertprozentige vermeidung jedes
risikos geben und das muss man ganz
deutlich auch an die adresse von herrn
lauterbach sagen der staat kann dieses
risiko nicht zu 100 prozent ausschließen
es gibt auch mit der striktesten panini
bekämpfung kein 100 keine 100 prozentige
sicherheit und deswegen ist jeder
beitrag jedes einheiten von abstands
hygieneregeln was man macht im privaten
bereich immer ein beitrag dazu die
wahrscheinlichkeit für eine infektion zu
senken
darum geht es und nur weil einmal
jemanden an jemand anders umarmt ist
doch nicht die ganze pandemie bekämpfung
damit erledigt wir waren 71 mal eine
aussage macht aber alle menschen können
jeden tag ihr verhalten wieder
korrigieren und daran mithelfen dass so
etwas nicht wieder passiert wir haben
sie einander angesprochen karl
lauterbach haben wir auch noch mal
gefragt welche maßnahmen er denn konkret
dabei gerne dabei hätte und das hat er
geantwortet
[Musik]
mit einem werden würde man versuchen die
schulen und aus so essentielle geschäfte
und auch die betriebe offen zu halten
dann würde aber im freizeitbereich alles
herunter fahren beispielsweise
restaurants gaststätten kneipen bars
fitnessclubs damit reduziert man für
zwei wochen die zahl der kontakte um 50
bis 75 prozent und wenn man das gemacht
hat ist man aus dem exponentiellen
wachstum für eine zeit lang wieder haus
mit einer solchen verschnaufpause wie
ich mal sagen könnte es uns gelingen bis
weihnachten zu kommen ohne einen
weiteren kompletten lockdown so also
kleiner zwischen bereits kleine zwischen
bremse statt kompletter locker und
klingt doch eigentlich erst mal
vernünftig herr kuhl und dass man dann
auch vielleicht sagen könnte man gibt
den gastronomen geld wenn man eine
entschädigung dass sie dicht machen
müssen aber halt nur für zwei wochen und
nicht für zwei monate
also natürlich macht das sinn darüber zu
diskutieren was herr lauterbach sagt
aber ich bin anderer auffassung und
kommen zu einem anderen ergebnis
denn wenn sie eine ein exponentielles
wachstum in einem bestimmten bereich
haben oder wenn sie eine region haben
einen stadtteil von berlin oder von
hamburg wo es ganz hohe infektionszahlen
gibt dann macht es natürlich auch keinen
sinn die schule offen zu lassen dann
muss die schule in diesem bereich
dichtgemacht werden umgekehrt kann es
aber sein dass wir dort wo weniger
bevölkerung ist fitness studios haben
beispielsweise oder gastronomiebetriebe
die auch in den nächsten wochen weiter
den betrieb offenhalten können also ist
muss auch unter den bedingungen einer so
genannten zweiten welle was auch immer
das heißt was auch immer mal darüber
darunter versteht weiterhin möglich sein
auch lokale und differenzierter ansätze
zu finden und vor allen dingen auch nach
der art des ausbruchs zu differenzieren
wenn sie einige junge menschen haben die
betroffen sind dann ist das schlimm dann
müssen die sich daran halten an abstands
und hygieneregeln
aber dann ist das nicht so schlimm wie
werden beispielsweise in einem alten
oder in einer betreuungseinrichtung oder
in einem altenheim ein ausbruch
stattfindet also es muss differenziert
werden nach den daten die wir haben nach
der art des ausbruchs und dann kann man
auch unter den bedingungen einer zweiten
welle oder unter den bedingungen die wir
jetzt haben in bestimmten bereichen ein
mindestmaß an öffentlichem leben
aufrechterhalten da wo es sinn macht
wenn es sinn
acht muss auch kontakt beschränkung
stattfinden aber es muss über
eingebracht werden mit dem was wir in
den letzten monaten gelernt haben sogar
collection es nochmal in die kommentare
da geht es hoch her
ich lese ein paar vor neben den üblichen
unflätigkeiten kommt jetzt hier robert
rohr und meint ich sei persönlich
ordentlich pro lockdown da müssen wir
kurz die rollen klären
herr kohler hat eine ziemlich klare
meinung und mein job ist einfach sie ihm
kontra zu geben was meine persönliche
meinung ist gut gerade überhaupt nichts
zur sache
vielleicht dass man zur klärung dann
gibt es hier schon mal hier auf youtube
habe ich gerade was gesehen
hp schreibt dort ich arbeite bei einem
großen stahlerzeuger noch ein lockdown
gibt der wirtschaft den rest und
maximilian weiß beschwert sich wieso hat
westeuropa keine einheitliche linie
wieso hat nicht einmal deutschland eine
einheitliche linie das ganze konzept ist
sowieso murks also große unzufriedenheit
höre ich hierher coole und eine frage
konz konkret an sie
die habe ich hier gerade gesehen muss
man kurz schauen da wolfgang ludwig
schrecken hervor ich soll sie doch mal
nach konkreten vorschlägen fragen er
erkenne bisher nur pauschalität also
konkrete vorschläge herr coole bitte wir
sollten uns darum kümmern dass nach der
art des ausbruchs differenziert wird wo
findet er statt in welcher region
wir sollten uns darum kümmern dass die
technischen neuerungen das ingenieurs
wissenschaftliche fragen wie
beispielsweise tauschen der raumluft wie
beispielsweise fragen der funktionsweise
von masken all diese sachen die wir in
den letzten monaten so ausführlich
miteinander diskutiert haben dass das in
den nächsten monaten eine rolle bei der
pandemie bekämpfung spielt das sind
konkrete vorschläge wie unterscheiden
sich auch von dem was er lauter war es
sagt viel wichtiger ist aber dass wir
diese unterschiedlichen vorschläge auch
mal im parlament diskutieren
wir sollten die sogenannte epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite so
abändern dass sie künftig nach zwei
monaten automatisch ausläuft der
bundestag muss das land immer verlängern
wir sollten die verordnungen erlassen
worden sind beispielsweise
einreisebestimmungen die sollten wir im
gesetzes wege diskutieren mit
spezialisten mit wissenschaftlern
sollten dazu eine anhörung mal im
bundestag machen wozu haben wir denn 709
gewählte bundestagsabgeordnete und 9 und
16 landtage wenn in dieser corona
pandemie alles von den
ministerpräsidenten entschieden wird und
die sich ganz unterschiedlich
widersprechen auch das hat ja in den
kommentaren der rolle gespielt
wir sollten uns letzter konkreter
vorschlag die grundlagen im
infektionsschutzgesetz noch mal ansehen
und sollten differenzieren nach
unterschiedlichen lebenssituationen also
eine rechtsgrundlage für die pflegeheime
eine rechtsgrundlage für die
krankenhäuser eine rechtsgrundlage
vielleicht auch für
bildungseinrichtungen dann sollten wir
mit einer corona ampel an die sich alle
ministerpräsidenten alle länder halten
jeweils ein gleiches raster für
deutschland haben wo aber
unterschiedlich reagiert werden kann je
nach der entwicklung vor ort
so jetzt hab ich mal versucht mit zu
beschreiben das waren fünf vorschläge
habe ich glaube ich richtig gezählt
einmal nach art des ausbruchs
unterscheiden dann sich die maßnahmen
besonders die schutzmaßnahmen nochmal
genauer angucken das dritte war die
parlamentarische kontrolle also quasi
die parlamente wieder mit reinnehmen das
infektionsschutzgesetz überarbeiten und
einem chor ohne ampel einführend so das
sind jetzt diese fünf konkreten
vorschläge aber da hat es bei mir schon
beim ersten coole wenn man nämlich die
art des ausbruches unterscheiden möchte
oder danach unterscheiden möchte dann
muss man ja wissen wo der ausbruch war
dann braucht man gesundheitsämter die
agieren können die quasi noch genug
personal haben das ganze zu
kontrollieren und das ist ja schon ein
problem in vielen landkreisen wir
sollten das jetzt noch funktionieren das
stimmt wir sollten vor allen dingen an
der digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter
dringend arbeiten
ich kann diesen satz am wochenende
melden nicht alle gesundheitsämter ihre
neuen corona infektion schon nicht mehr
hören natürlich müssen wir wissen wie
sich die infektion in einer bestimmten
region entwickeln denn das virus macht
ja keinen unterschied ob samstag oder
donnerstag ist also die digitalisierung
der gesundheitsämter die muss dringend
voranschreiten auch damit man menschen
bei denen es ein positives ergebnis gibt
schnell über ihren ausbruch oder über
ihre infektion informiert das was da in
bayern passiert ist dieses chaos was er
so da da angerichtet hat das hat sich
wirklich auf das schicksal von vielen
menschen ausgewirkt und das hätte man
wirklich verhindern können indem man die
gesundheitsämter früher digitalisiert
aber wenn ich mir jetzt ein gucke was
hier noch so vorschlagen dann muss ich
sagen das sind zwar diskutable
vorschläge aber doch alles sachen die
vielleicht auch
sagen manche menschen in der regierung
macht besser diskutiert wenn man mit der
pandemie durch ist weil es hat doch
dauern kann der digitalisierung kommt
nicht von heute auf morgen gerade in den
gesundheitsämtern nicht also natürlich
muss die regierung schnell und
pragmatisch handeln das musste sie merkt
dass musste sie im april
und ich finde es auch richtig dass wir
gesundheitsminister haben die alles
menschenmögliche unternehmen um dieser
pandemie herr zu werden ich nehme den
übrigens ab dass sie alles tun um diese
pandemie zu bekämpfen aber wir müssen
die gewaltenteilung auch in corona
zeiten erhalten und wenn es so weit
reichende grundrechts einschränkungen
gibt es das leben der menschen jeden tag
in einer weise dadurch beeinträchtigt
ist wie nie zuvor kann solche
grundrechts einschränkungen kann sich
niemand erinnern in deutschland dann
müssen wir das auch in den parlamenten
diskutieren und dann muss auch die
einbindung unterschiedlicher fachleute
in den parlamenten der stärkere rolle
spielt und dann kann es muss es auch
erlaubt sein dass wir ein bisschen über
den tag hinaus denken und beispielsweise
über eine über einen besseren einsatz
der digitalisierung nachdenken das ist
ja auch möglich gewesen
innerhalb weniger wochen und monate eine
corona app zu programmieren und auf den
weg zu bringen mit der einzelne bürger
einen kontakt tracing mehr machen können
warum es nicht möglich ist innerhalb
weniger monate die gesundheitsämter auf
einen stand zu bringen dass diese corona
meldung digital ans lka weiter mittel
und nicht per fax das erschließt sich
mir nicht
jetzt gibt es hier noch einige fragen
versucht die gerade ein bisschen zu
ordnen
zum beispiel michael sachs lotto
niedersachsen otto tschuldigung auf
facebook ich arbeite in warnemünde in
einem restaurant das ist ein beliebter
touristenort an der ostsee was wir jeden
tag für gäste haben die sich immer noch
nicht an die masken pflicht halten gehen
und ohne maske in den laden haben massen
unter der nase stellen die frage wie
jetzt muss ich hier masken tragen und
das wird märz immer noch das heißt hier
höre ich würde ich erst mal deuten eine
skepsis heraus dass die menschen
tatsächlich eigenverantwortlich handeln
und das auch einsehen was sie da machen
müssen uns wenn wir es war vielleicht
mal über diese parlamentarische
kontrolle reden noch mal ganz kurz die
es jetzt immer wieder angeführt haben
quasi und warum haben wir so viele
parlamentarier wenn die nichts abnicken
dürfen ja nicht nur abnicken sondern
auch mal attackieren dürfen sie gar
nicht gefragt werden
da habe ich karl lauterbach vor zwei
wochen schon mal gefragt und er hat
gesagt ja wir haben das immer wieder
geprüft im gesundheitsausschuss ob diese
epigenetische rager noch da ist auch für
quasi eingreifen müssen oder nicht das
war nicht der fall von daher haben wir
das jetzt einfach mal so gelassen würden
sie da dem gesundheitsausschuss
widersprechen
nämlich ärgert das was karl lauterbach
da sagt weil wir natürlich jetzt eine
situation haben wo die zahlen andere
sind als beispielsweise im juni und im
juli und eines will ich ganz eindeutig
sagen wir können nicht die beschränkung
der gewaltenteilung und die beschränkung
der rechte des parlaments
aufrechterhalten weil es ab weil es in
der pandemie bequem ist also die
argumente die wir im mai im juni im juli
gehört haben die waren war es könnte ja
im herbst wieder etwas schlimmer werden
dann ist es doch besser wir lassen die
rechte gleich bei der regierung und
holen sie nicht zurück zum parlament wie
sagst das ist nicht mein verständnis als
parlamentarischer da müssen wir jetzt
ran
das was warum ist das bequem was meinen
sie damit hatten haben die
parlamentarier an ihren augen angst vor
verantwortung
ja ich glaube es ist bequem wenn wenige
personen in der exekutive eine
entscheidung treffen und das nicht mit
709 bundestagsabgeordneten und mit 16
landtagen rückkoppeln müssen ist ja klar
wenn man sich einfach hinsetzen kann als
gesundheitsminister und eine corona
verordnung schreibt dann kommt die am
nächsten tag ins verkündung blatt des
landes alle bürger müssen sich daran
halten
und man hat die elendigen diskussion in
der fraktion nicht man hat nicht
irgendwelche journalisten die noch mal
nachbohren man hat die große debatte im
plenum nicht also es ist viel bequemer
das problem ist die qualität der
rechtssetzung nimmt ab und ich sage das
auch ganz offen als
bundestagsabgeordneter der viele der
korona maßnahmen auch verteidigt ich
glaube wir müssen vorbilder sein wir
müssen darüber sprechen dass eine masken
pflicht sinnvoll ist dass man sich daran
halten muss aber ich persönlich habe
keine lust durchs land zu fahren und den
menschen corona verordnungen zu erklären
von denen ich selber aus der zeitung
erfahre und die dann eine woche später
wieder von gerichten kassiert werden wie
beispielsweise das unsinnige
beherbergungs verbot ich das war von der
qualität der rechtssetzung ja schlecht
ja das hätte man vermeiden können wenn
man so was vorher in den landtagen
diskutiert hätte ich habe hier einen
kommentar gehabt sinnsuche ich gerade
aber ich finde nicht mehr weil wir haben
viele auf facebook da ging in die
richtung herr kohler wie soll dann bitte
einen parlament in dem es ja auch immer
drei lesungen braucht und dann muss das
ganze noch durch den bundesrat bis man
quasi wirklich eingesetzt hat dass man
so veröffentlichen kann
wie soll das denn
halb von 24 bis 48 stunden gehen gerade
wenn es eine pandemische lage ist wo wie
die experten ja sagen ist und jeden tag
geht also im märz haben wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz sehr schnell
geändert dieses verfahren hat eine woche
nur gedauert und da sind alle lesungen
in einer woche durchgeführt worden hat
das ganze sehr schnell auf den weg
gebracht und wir haben am ende sogar
auch eine sitzung des bundesrates
gemacht jetzt gerade in dieser woche
findet eine sitzungswoche des deutschen
bundestages statt die bundeskanzlerin
hält am donnerstag eine
regierungserklärung das ist genau
richtig im anschluss daran beantragen
wir als fraktion der fdp auch eine
ausweitung der parlamentsbeteiligung das
könnte man jetzt zum anlass nehmen hier
ganz konkrete maßnahmen auf den weg zu
bringen beispielsweise das
infektionsschutzgesetz genauer
auszugestalten beispielsweise einzelne
verordnung in den gesetzesweg zu
überführen und nächste woche ist auch
alle sitzungswoche die stattfinden wird
im bundestag unter einhaltung von
abstands und hygieneregeln und da könnte
man dann die zweite und dritte lesung
machen also wenn man das will dann geht
das auch und unsere demokratie unsere
parlamentarische demokratie
da müssen wir uns auch ein bisschen
anstrengend und ein bisschen kreativ
sein dass so was im pandemie bedingungen
auch möglich aber herr coole es gibt
noch eine andere fraktionen die es gar
nicht so klein das ist die zweitgrößte
ob alter die größte oppositionsfraktion
im bundestag die ist im grunde würde mal
sagen jetzt so ganz grob inhaltlich auf
ihrer linie findet auch das geht alles
nicht die parlamentarier müssen
eingebunden werden wir brauchen diese
ganzen maßnahmen in dem fall jetzt nicht
da sind sie nicht konform das weiß ich
aber zumindest geht sie auch da in die
opposition was ihr job ist die afd
haben sie nicht angst dass ihr daher
kapert werden von von rechts und dann
auf einmal wieder da stehen und ihnen
vorgeworfen wird der die fdp macht mit
der afg gemeinsam gemeinsame sache gegen
die bundesregierung also wenn ich durch
den bundestag laufe dann fällt mir
erstmal auch wie wenige menschen dort
noch unterwegs sind das liegt unter
anderem daran dass viele unserer
mitarbeiterin und mitarbeiter längst von
zu hause aus arbeiten für uns
abgeordnete selber ist das nicht möglich
wenn man dann alleine im büro ist dann
ist auch gewahrt dass man kein
infektionsrisiko oder nur ein geringes
infektionsrisiko hat wenn ich da durch
den bundestag laufe dann sehe ich aber
ganz viele fdp-abgeordnete die bewusst
und mit absicht keine maske tragen und
damit wirklich den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern angst machen wir haben es
hier mit einer fraktion von corona
leugnern und verschwörungstheoretikern
zu tun
die stadt zu ersetzen sind die afg
gesagt ja selber je schlechter ist im
land geht umso besser für
rechtspopulisten wie die afd
und die machen das nur um sozusagen ihr
eigenes süppchen zu kochen und um
möglichst destruktiv diese krise zu
begleiten das erkennt man auch an den
anträgen die sie in den bundestag
einbringen die teilweise verheerende
folgen für die pandemie bekämpfung haben
also man muss schon selbst bewusst als
parlamentarier einer demokratischen
oppositionspartei klar machen das was
die bundesregierung da macht das sehen
wir anders und gleichzeitig sich von
rechtspopulisten wie afg abgrenzen so
wir schalten mal einen die youtube
kommentare wo es immer mehr zuschauer
werden gerade und da kommt hat ist mein
flieger dazu gekommen und stellt die
frage ich bin erst gerade dazu
geschaltet wie sieht's jetzt aus gibt es
einen neuen look down also wir fassen
noch mal zusammen ich spreche gerade mit
dem innenpolitischen sprecher der fdp
bundestagsfraktion konstantin coole der
schon figuriert ist hat deswegen gerne
mal zum glas wasser greifen darf über
die frage ob es einen neuen faktoren
geben sollte oder shutdown oder eine
kontrakt beschränkungen was immer nennen
möchte oder nicht das ganze wird
wahrscheinlich morgen entschieden oder
diskutiert zwischen bundeskanzlerin
merkel und den ministerpräsidenten der
bundesländer daran gibt es kritik unter
anderem von herrn coole der sagt es kann
nicht sein dass die immer alles alleine
entscheiden sondern die parlamente
müssen mal wieder befragt werden die
sind seit monaten quasi in dieser ganzen
pandemie frage völlig außer gefecht
gesetzt und können immer nur zugucken
wieder was beschlossen wird wir haben
schon diskutiert über die vorschläge es
gibt dort viele vorschläge ich kann doch
mal kurz zusammenfassen wenn ich das
hier finde auf meinen zettel darfst du
seite 1 also die wissenschaftler der
deutschen nationalen
wissenschaftsakademie leopoldina und
andere forschungsgemeinschaften haben
gefordert dass es eine drastische
reduzierung von sozialen kontakten gibt
genau wie der virologe christian drosten
der spd gesundheitspolitiker karl
lauterbach möchte einen sogenannten
wellenbrecher shutter und ist ein
schönes bild also quasi einen kurzen
prägnanten stopp des öffentlichen lebens
zwei drei wochen lang sollen die meisten
sachen geschlossen werden so dass man
dann wieder zu hause bleibt und sich
möglichst nicht raus bewegt um dann
quasi die stark wachsenden zahlen
aufzuhalten so und das ganze ist jetzt
aber die frage ob das eine gute idee ist
der coole ist der meinung nein
wir sollten vor allem gastronomie und
hotel weiter aufhalten kleinkunst
betriebe auch kleinere betriebe die
möglichkeit geben weiter offen zu sein
weil die halt am stärksten leiden so
jetzt haben wir über die wirtschaft noch
gar nicht geredet dabei ist das doch das
kernthema mit der fdp immer hier gab es
auch diverse kommentare so noch ein
weiterer shutdown
macht uns die wirtschaft komplett kaputt
das funktioniert nichts das können wir
nicht machen wir gucken mal auf die
aktuellen zahlen dass die sagen
in der wirtschaft wächst die sorge vor
den folgen eines möglichen zweiten lok
downs gaststätten cafés und caterer
wären wohl wieder besonders stark
betroffen
sie hatten bereits zwischen märz und
august laut statistischem bundesamt ein
umsatzminus von etwa 40 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr um fast ein
fünftel schrumpfte die zahl der
beschäftigten noch heftiger der einbruch
der zahlen im flugverkehr im zweiten
quartal 2020 starteten von deutschen
flughäfen aus nur etwa 1,1 millionen
fluggäste im vorjahreszeitraum waren es
laut euro statt noch 33,7 millionen
ebenfalls schwer gebeutelt die kultur
und kreativbranche kaum konzerte und
veranstaltungen statt dessen
geschlossene kulturstätten die
bundesregierung rechnet hier mit
umsatzeinbußen bis zu 28 milliarden euro
ja also schon heftiger summen aber wie
wollen wir verhindern dass das ganze
noch mal so schlimm kommt wenn wir quasi
jetzt der ganzen pandemie freien lauf
lassen das ist ja eine befürchtung der
coole dass der mann das jetzt quasi
nicht eindämmt und das einfach laufen
lässt dass das längere lockdown
irgendwann geben muss die dann
bestimmten betrieben massiven schaden
zufügen
genau wir müssen auch beachten dass eine
auswirkung des corona virus und eine
auswirkung von einschneidenden maßnahmen
je einschneiden dass sie sind natürlich
ganz erhebliche auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung im land
haben das aber ja auch hier an den
kommentaren gesehen aber wir müssen
berücksichtigen erstens wirtschaftliches
wachstum und die gesundung unserer
volkswirtschaft und auch wieder
sozusagen ein anschub in bestimmten
bereichen ist kein widerspruch für
gesundheitsversorgung
sondern ist geradezu die voraussetzung
für sozialleistungen und für ein
funktionierendes gesundheitssystem wir
reden gerade darüber dass das
kurzarbeitergeld verlängert werden soll
bis über die bundestagswahl hinaus in
allen branchen wo soll denn dieses geld
herkommen soll das wieder bezahlt werden
aus den rücklagen der
arbeitslosenversicherung das wird nicht
gehen weil diese rücklagen weitestgehend
aufgebraucht sind es braucht also
steuereinnahmen oder es werden schulden
gemacht die dann von der nächsten
generation bezahlt werden also wer in
dieser situation auch an die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung im land
denkt der denkt an ganz konkrete
schicksale von menschen deren familien
deren familien da dranhängen der denkt
aber auch an die gesundung unserer
volkswirtschaft als grundlage für die
finanzierung des gesundheitssystems wie
der finanzierung des kurzarbeitergeldes
und anderes und ein zweiter punkt wir
können nicht die gesamte wirtschaft über
einen kamm scheren wir werden womöglich
erleben dass die hier im beitrag
dargestellt flugindustrie oder das
sozusagen der der bereich der lufthansa
et cetera dass die noch über viele
monate große probleme haben werden
ähnliches gilt für den messebau
ähnliches gilt für viele bereiche der
veranstaltungsbranche
und hier muss man beispielsweise auch
über eine verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeldes nachdenken in anderen
bereichen aber wenn wir an die industrie
denken und auch das hat in den
kommentaren ja eine rolle gespielt da
sind mittlerweile so tolle konzepte
implementiert worden dass man in
mehreren schichten beispielsweise
arbeitet das man mitarbeiter voneinander
trennt auch hier hat man sich in den
letzten monaten vieles überlegt um
gerade für herbst und winter vorbereitet
zu sein also die leute haben sich
gedanken gemacht haben investiert damit
sie arbeiten können und denen darf man
jetzt keine knüppel zwischen die beine
schmeißen sondern sollte es ihnen
ermöglichen auch weiter zu arbeiten so
und da gibt es natürlich auch von karl
lauterbach eine etwas andere position
den haben wir heute
heute nachmittag interviewt wir wollten
ihn eigentlich gerne auch dazu schalten
aber es hat terminlich nicht geklappt
hier also sein statement zur
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
[Musik]
die wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
wären viel größer wenn wir zu spät
handeln denn wenn wir später handeln
dann kommt der komplette lockdown wir
werden darüber hinaus auch sehr viele
menschen leben verlieren das muss man
realistisch sehen
das jetzige wachstum hatten wir noch
wenige wochen dann sind die intensiv
plätze überbelegt dann müssen wir
möglicherweise menschen sterben sie in
die wir vorher hätten retten können das
müssen wir verhindern somit die sozialen
und auch die ökonomischen folgen des
späteren handelns während viel
gravierender so das scheint jetzt aber
doch eine uneinigkeit zu geben herr
coole oder also herr lauterbach sagt
wenn man nicht erst nicht handelt wird
später schlimmer sie sagen besser offen
lassen damit es überhaupt nicht schlimm
wird hab ich sie richtig verstanden
naja ich finde das ärgerlich dass herr
lauterbach den eindruck erweckt wir
würden von der fdp oder andere kritiker
der aktuellen corona politik würden
maßnahmen vorschlagen die nichts bringen
das gegenteil ist der fall
es müssen maßnahmen jetzt unternommen
werden die geeignet sind das wachstum
der infektionszahlen zu bremsen es
müssen maßnahmen unternommen werden die
geeignet sind das die die das versterben
von vielen menschen verhindert wird also
das bild was hier gezeichnet wird von
lauterbach das entspricht einfach nicht
den tatsachen wir sondern wir sollten
darüber diskutieren was bringt denn
wirklich was und da haben wir eine tolle
diskussion finde ich über den ganzen
sommer hinweg geführt in welchen
bereichen wir den tatsächlich eine
problematische infektions entwicklung
haben und ich verstehe einfach nicht
warum in einem restaurant nach 23 uhr
das infektionsrisiko oder nach 22 uhr
größer sein soll als vor 22 uhr in
respektabler in den sog und jugendliche
das hätte begründung dass sich da viel
mehr leute zusammen mit der anzahl der
leute die sich daran auf rein
die begründung ist jedoch immer dass wir
den menschen alkohol konsumiert haben ab
20 uhr ab 350 irgendwann die
hemmschwellen sinken mit man sich doch
halt um den hals fällt wie das herr
linden auch passiert ist natürlich muss
es nach muss es sozusagen beschränkungen
geben dass so etwas nicht erlaubt ist
dass man abstand und hygiene regeln
einhält aber viele menschen die mehrzahl
der menschen in deutschland gehört zur
arbeitenden bevölkerung die am nächsten
tag auch wieder aufstehen
auch im home office und wieder arbeiten
und die
offen sich nicht jeden abend und
knutschen sich jeden abend oder in
welchen bars ab das macht man vielleicht
mal am wochenende aber nicht jeden abend
und deswegen muss es auch für die
gastronomie muss es auch für kleine
betriebe muss es für die bereich der
kultur wirtschaft muss es für den
bereich der kreativwirtschaft ein
überleben in den nächsten wochen in den
nächsten monaten geben so ich schau
jetzt nochmal abschließend in die
kommentare da geht es hoch her wir haben
viele kommentare auch auf youtube ich
schau mal hier nochmal rein da schreibt
hens
deren meinung auf meinen rechner
schalten dann können wir es auch sehen
sollte nicht schnell eine reaktion auf
die steigenden infektionen stattfinden
wenn man nicht bald reagiert ist ein
lockdown ja nicht vermeidbar das ist so
die eine wortmeldung dann eine
wortmeldung von ulrich janssen
parlamente befragt man nicht exekutive
muss sich von parlamenten legitimieren
lassen
hercules er als parlamentarier können
das vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
erklären was da passiert ist warum ist
das gerade nicht der fall also wir haben
ja die gewaltenteilung in deutschland
und die sieht vor dass direkt dass die
regierung gesetzte anwendet die vom
parlament gemacht werden und wir haben
es zu tun momentan mit einem modus der
nennt sich rechtsverordnung der so ein
bisschen eine zwitterstellung innehat
zwischen parlament und regierung auf den
beiden seiten denn bei einer verordnung
handelt es sich um eine generelle
regelung an die sich alle menschen
handeln erhalten müssen uns für so was
ist eigentlich das parlament zuständig
das parlament kann sowas aber delegieren
auf die regierung die große frage ist
schon seit vielen jahrzehnten
jahrhunderten fast umstritten ist wie
weit darf man da gehen und ich würde
sagen und wir als fdp würden sagen also
am anfang der pandemie konnte man da
relativ weit gehen denn wir wussten noch
sehr wenig über dieses virus und
deswegen musste die regierung sehr
schnell und sehr pragmatisch handeln
können jetzt wissen wir aber etwas mehr
und deswegen muss der handlungsspielraum
für die regierung durch das parlament
wieder eingeschränkt werden und dafür
braucht es aber selbstbewusste
parlamentarier die nicht nur im
fernsehen dinge erzählen sondern die das
am ende auch im bundesgesetzblatt durch
eine eigene entscheidung zum gegenstand
von tatsächliche politik machen und ich
lade alle kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade aus cdu csu und spd ein daran
diese woche mitzuwirken
gut per kohle vielen dank für ihre zeit
andere abend in den kommentaren jetzt
immer noch hoch her wir haben hier sehr
viele fragen auch teilweise sehr
speziell die wäre es für die nicht
beantworten können das wird zum beispiel
gefragt der coole was sie davon halten
dass man in berlin jetzt auf dem fahrrad
masken tragen soll das habe ich noch gar
nicht mitbekommen aber ich glaube das
geht jetzt wirklich zu sehr ins detail
das können wir heute abend nicht mehr
erklären aber ich freue mich wenn ihr
beim nächsten mal wieder dabei seid
lasst uns doch gerne an neukunden abo da
kommentare werden wir auf jeden fall
weiter noch bearbeiten da wurde auch
gerade schon gefragt ob es keine admin
es gibt doch gibt es aber es ist einfach
natürlich jetzt sehr viel aufgelaufen
hier in den letzten 30 minuten dann
müssen wir noch einmal mit dem kärcher
durch und einmal durch freundin und
gucken was haben hinten daher noch übrig
bleibt davon ein cooler vielen dank für
ihre zeit heute auch sehr gerne hat spaß
gemacht und euch und ihnen vielen dank
für die kommentare und die fragen das
zum nächsten mal